cosas que hacer antes de los 20 según mi
lógica de 11 años que debía estar en una
banda de rock yo debía aprender a tocar
el saxofón debía aprender repostería en
cinco idiomas dejar por el mundo todo
esto antes de los 20 años
esto me puso a pensar un poco más de
cerca de niñez
durante esta etapa yo me sentía muy
pequeña para hacer muchas cosas pero
también a veces muy grande para hacer
otras esto en el medio y eso realmente
me molestaba yo que ya sería el mundo
quería salir a las calles sola comprarme
un vestido una pulsera sin que los
vendedores me vieran raro a la hora de
pagar
yo quería ser independiente pero a la
vez tenía miedo de no poder hacer todas
estas cosas realistas antes de cumplir
los 20
hoy tengo 17 años estoy acá sin nada de
cumplir mis 18 años y muchas de esas
tareas no las he completado
algunas y
pero esto me puso a reflexionar y hoy en
día creo que todo es posible
solo hace falta un ingrediente secreto
conforme vamos creciendo nuestra visión
de vida cambia es decir nuestros gustos
habilidades y metas son los que nos
definen sin embargo qué pasa cuando
estos gustos mis metas y habilidades
es aquí cuando me pregunto quién soy
es aquí cuando comienza un nuevo juego
directivas
es el momento perfecto para voltear
sobre el espejo y 250 de lo que ha
cambiado
y ustedes y yo somos la misma persona
que éramos hace una semana o ayer
protégeme decirles que esto es lo que
nos hace infinitos
si infinitas quiero que recuerden muy
bien esta palabra
tenemos miles y millones de
posibilidades delante de nosotros pero
solo existe una persona que nos puede
impulsar a conocernos
bueno ahora debe practicarla es un
poquito más acerca de la motivación
regularmente cuando queremos conseguir
algo existe una razón o motivación
detrás por si ustedes sacan excelentes
calificaciones y sus padres les promete
que les compran en un coche
bueno tal vez si no hubiese existido esa
posibilidad
su esfuerzo hubiese sido menos
qué es lo que los impulsos
su mamá
ganar dinero o tal vez el famoso
todo aquello que nos impulse a vivir
es lo que hay que considerar
quiero que se pregunten a sí mismos
te mediría millón de 79 años si me viera
ahora
quería algo diferente
es aquí cuando está el secreto
para mí la mejor motivación que existe
somos nosotros mismos
pero cómo le hago como la consigo
bueno el secreto es volver a encontrar a
nuestro niño interior
miren un niño no tiene preocupaciones no
contemple el tiempo un niño se dedica
hace feliz a vivir a soñar ser niño es
una aventura
también durante esta etapa de la niñez
cada uno de nosotros desarrollamos algo
que permanece con nosotros hasta el día
de nuestra muerte
una esencia
una esencia que nos caracteriza y nos
diferencia de otros nos hace únicos esto
puede ser desde una mueca una frase o
tal vez un hábito
por ejemplo yo yo acostumbro agarrarme
la oreja cuando tengo sueño
y tal vez sea lo que sigue siendo hasta
que tenga 40
hasta el día
también ha habido días en los que no hay
tanto tiempo
digo
quiero más de 24 horas
pero también ha habido otros en los que
estoy en mi primera segunda clase y vivo
ojalá que el día se pase rápido que ya
se acabe
el tiempo es nuestra mayor obsesión nos
controla y constantemente
buscamos apropiarnos de él
porque queremos correr aquí no hace
tiempo me dijo que respuesta los 15 años
la vida se te va volando
de repente pase a la universidad de
gradúas y esa persona que quería hacer
ahora existe el tiempo es esencial es
algo que tenemos que considerar para
nuestras vidas sin embargo no es lo
primordial
un niño disfruta sonríe
no se preocupa por tener que hacer las
cosas rápido y que no le voy a alcanzar
gente no llega a los 30 años y no ha
logrado no
ser niño es una aventura
ahora me gustaría hacerlo solucionar un
poco acerca de cómo es que se voltean a
ver
nuestro niño interior es es y siempre
será nuestra voz
por eso yo les voy a proponer que
escriban una carta escribo lo suficiente
escriban sus miedos reconozcan los pero
también escriban aquello que les
gustaría verse haciendo en un futuro
esta carta guarden esconda la y dentro
de unos años unos días o unos meses
vuelva ya zetas lean atrevan a verse a
sí mismos con honestidad
recuerden si no le dices al niño que la
montaña hermosa está muy alta
el niño de su mirada
dejen de lado esas opiniones críticas
externas no sean su propio elegido
son sus propulsores
e impulsase hacia arriba y no duden de
que llegarán a la cima
hoy en día
y creo firmemente que este mundo le
hacen falta más licenciados en sacar
sonrisas
esta carta
es una prueba honesta hacia ustedes
mismos
además no tengan miedo no priman su
vulnerabilidad tener miedo está bien
muchas veces como jóvenes decimos nada
es seguro a esta edad tendemos a buscar
una carrera o un trabajo que pague bien
por miedo a no cubrir todos esos lujos o
laicos que vemos en redes sociales
tener novio o novia atrae problemas y de
repente existe el miedo y compromiso
porque queremos correr
la vida adulta está cada vez más cercana
si asusta
pero vamos a llegar en algún momento a
ellas
lo más importante es recordar quiénes
somos
recordar todas aquellas risas carcajadas
lágrimas todo eso es lo más valioso que
tenemos valor en cada pequeño detalle
créanme que hace la diferencia
ustedes son su razón de existir todo
aquello que logré
será por ustedes mismos
recuerden escuchar a su niño interior
estoy segura de que ese vídeo quisiera
pasar más tiempo riendo y jugando
disfrutando de los momentos y de las
oportunidades
este niño no quería estar estresado por
sacar excelentes calificaciones y
complacer a sus padres
valor es aquello que la vida él está
dado y utilizarlo como su razón de ser
hagan lo que hagan no apaguen su esencia
es lo que mantiene vivo a su niño
interior dejen que estados quiere que
los motive
no tengan miedo no priman esa
vulnerabilidad
porque créanme
que cuando más oscura crean que es la
habitación
más posibilidades hay para ustedes de
aprender sus nuevas cosas
escuchen a su niño interior
atreverse a verse con la honestidad
te escuchen a su niño interior y
atreverse a vivir su gran aventura
recuerden
reír no es un lujo es una necesidad
y ustedes son los encargados de
convertirse en esos licenciados en sacar
sonrisas principalmente para ustedes
escuchen a su niño interior y atrevan a
vivir esta gran aventura
que soy
gracias
[Aplausos]